comme un fol belmondo qu'est-ce qui m'a
[Musique]
lui aussi précis dany boon
non
toute l'année lui l'hypnose et c'est
l'amour
il sait
[Musique]
il chante non plus bouger au rythme de
ce calibre à l'oreille comment ça va ça
va pas mal bien on a eu votre compagne
oui c'est chaud c'est comme ça qu'on dit
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que j'ai
découvert l'émission
voilà ma femme l'a fait tout le temps et
sans arêtes
alors je lui dit quand tu veux un tu
reviens tu est la bienvenue ça vous
embête quand on vous dit que vous êtes
le mari de judith godrèche
non pas du tout ça me flatte quand elle
est venue on lui a demandé si elle vous
bourre utiliser si elle avait pris
possession de votre esprit elle a dit
non non de demande de mon corps et
parfois de mon esprit ça va
libre-arbitre vous pouvez faire tout ce
que c'est au début les premiers gains du
jour j'ai déjà ça le mieux est des fois
ça revient défense en la regardant
mais on a raconté plein de trucs on a
raconté que vous aviez une oreillette
pour le spectacle qu'elle vous parlé
dans l'oreillette
le premier soir à la première est la
toute première j'avais très peur je suis
de deux heures de spectacle c'est très
long à apprendre et je l'avais je le
savais en fait mais j'avais très peur
donc j'avais effectivement une
oreillette et judith me disait tout le
texte alors qu'elle était censée me le
dire que quand j'avais des trous mais
elle avait peur que j'ai un temps de
silence mais ce texte elle me donnait
fake
sous partage c'est terrible on cherche
une oreillette on dit tout ce que je
dois vous dire a dit ok j'ai donc vous
êtes rencontrés sur le plateau de bimbo
landes
oui avec il y avait hors tout le monde
c'est mon fils m'a finalement il a eu
une certaine importance
c'est vrai oui mais rendent tellement
aujourd'hui mais je suis sur un
bimboland il a marché très fort en
allemagne on va parler de leur nouveau
spectacle
vous savez comment on fait cher dany
boon vient bien bien sûr et tout le
monde est très discipliné ce soir
mise en scène par judith godrèche bien
au casino de paris donc alors j'ai eu la
même réaction que jérôme béglé de paris
match
parce que j'ai lu le papier il dit mot
sur le voir dany boon moi je n'avais
jamais vu sur scène un don qui y est
allé qui savait pas très bien ce que
c'était en fait j'avais vu chez drucker
mais parce que jamais sur scène et il se
demandait si c'est allé lui plaire et
moi aussi
et puis moi ça m'a plu et lui aussi oui
c'est vrai il dit j'ai même en poussant
la porte gersal et je m'emmerde être un
truc et je me suis marré pas seulement
parce que j'avais juste à côté de moi
vraiment me suis regardé si je me marre
est allé très présente avec des coups de
coude non dans les camps mais alors deux
ans d'écriture enfin d'écriture depuis
les notes dans les bistrots cessa dos
des bistrots chalet dans des bistrots
prix des bières et des notes sur les
dessous de boeck
ouais et puis un jour celle en vacances
au soleil vous classez vos notes et ça
fait un spectacle oui oui
sympa comme boulot à décrire c'est
génial mais en plus c'est payé et où on
parle on veut le lien entre tous les
personnages c'est quoi si la névrose
je suivrai animateur de tv s'amenant
daniela lumbroso aurait pu dire ça oui
daniela c'est
j'ai admiré en ce moment bon que je
fasse attention on va gagner la vie
n'est qu'un jeu pour toi je vais
regarder à quoi ça ressemble à nier
d'auxerre
en salle c'est dany boon qui fait mike
brant donc à la fin du spectacle une
idée de judo a je crois qu'on peut le
dire exactement elle le dit dans l'eure
je le répète je lui dit tu vois je suis
très disciplinés moi aussi bien
alors maintenant moi je vous ai connu
donc en voyant ce spectacle au casino de
paris
et puis aussi en étudiant votre
dans votre vie votre vrai nom c'est
daniel hamidou et dany boon en fait
c'est le nom d'un héros de séries en
fait non d'un trappeur c'est un copain
qui vous daniel boone il s'appelle le
héros et qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a existé
d'ailleurs qui était un canadien qui a
traversé l'alaska
voilà à pied ah oui comme ça bien et
donc c'est venu logiquement alors vous
êtes né à armentières un point bas mais
fier en 1966 et vous savez laurent
qu'armentières c'est le pays de sissel
céline renaud la chanson de line renaud
sur sont méconnus ce n'est pas ça elle a
fait des trucs grave aussi line renaud
votre père vient de kabylie est arrivée
en france à ces jeunes était boxeur il
est quelques victoires d'ailleurs sur le
ring à alger à marseille sa vie en tant
de la boxe en faisant de la boxe et puis
un jour il a raccroché les gants et il a
pris le volant d'un 3 tonnes à 38 1 3
tonne c'est par un camion s'est même pas
le poids d'une voiture
[Applaudissements]
l'autre gros cul qui connaît un 38
tonnes
[ __ ] j'ai pas le permis en même temps
moi comme j'ai dit voilà donc voilà donc
un jour il raccroche les gants il prend
les commandes d'un gros camion disons à
patates et tous les matins il va faire
le plein de super dans une
station-service kergoal de gasoil
[Musique]
le réseau la télé tu t'appelais pas max
meynier jusque et transporte bien donc
tout cas l'arrière il ya une sorte de
grande cabine c'est pas un appartement
d'accord les bisons des marchandises et
donc tous les matins il va faire le
plein de gasoil dans la station service
des parents de votre mère voilà et un
jour votre mère se retrouve enceinte
parce que derrière il ya aussi il ya une
couchette
quand votre merde se retrouve enceinte
elle a 17 ans a eu 36 son commentaire
s'est excusé ouais et vos grands-parents
coupe les vivres donc c'est vrai sérieux
qu'ils ont été obligés d'habiter dans le
camion moment oui c'est vrai il s'est
invité dans parce que mes grands parents
s'ils n'ont pas supporté l'idée way que
ma mère soit enceinte surtout d'un
étranger c'est aussi un drame
tu pars ouais donc elle est partie dans
le camion c'est mes arrière grands
parents qui ont aidé mais c'est sympa ça
je savais pas oui oui oui c'est sympa ça
je savais pas du tout alors votre maire
bah oui est obligé de faire des ménages
parce que c'est compliqué il ya en plus
de petits frères qui arrive et puis un
jour il décide d'acheter cette fameuse
maison mais en deux corps ont à crédit
c'est vrai parce qu'on va voir la fin là
je on va voir comment ce l'histoire la
maison se termine c'est pour ça que je
dis ça j'ai une chute bien enfance très
dure pour vous
là on rigole mais bon enfance très dure
père très sévère relations
conflictuelles ça se traduisait comment
le ceinturon ou militer boxeur il ya des
heures sup
les anglais un père buteux salle en même
temps
vous êtes un enfant dany boon assez
introverti
à l'époque oui c est presque autiste et
vous quitter le foyer familial à l'âge
de 15 16 ans oui oui c'est ça 15 ans
alors bas dans cette enfance évidemment
vous de puiser de quoi faire ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de
thérapie en fait
en fait j'aimerais beaucoup j'étais très
introverti je parlais pas énormément je
regardais les gens quoi et je vais
fouiller les copains de mon père ou le
et donc oui et puis j'ai observé quand
même mis une galerie de personnages dans
votre spectacle et votre mère alors y
avait un truc c'est qu'elle racontait
des choses horribles en star d'andré un
oui ok sélectivement vous c'est ce que
vous faites fi nalement wings adjoint
recquois et les gens étaient atterrés l
aile avec lille bien ouais elle tournait
en dérision les journées tout en
dérision
alors l'histoire voilà j'en arrive à
l'histoire de la maison parce que c'est
pas innocent ils vont divorcer un peu
comme les parents de marie gillain
je suis devenu un spécialiste manipule
et vous vos parents divorcent après 25
ans et ils ont vendu cette maison il est
passé leur vie à la payer cette maison
il a vendu pour cent mille balles c'est
magique ce pourquoi votre mère à contrer
ça sur mon smartphone mais c'est un peu
dur ll ça tout le monde serait mort de
rire à ses hôtes moi non mais bon 25 ans
de boulot et puis puissant mille balles
oui mais bon mes parents fin mon père
était très très heureux de son métier
ils aiment et ce qu'ils faisaient
donc voilà il gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent mais ça allait ouais alors
votre père qu'il n'a pas connu votre
succès est décédé avant c'est un peu
dommage parce que début il avait du mal
à accepter ou facile ça oui oui il avait
dû y avait du mal à accepter que je
fasse ils voulaient pas non il disait
je les jouais vraiment bien faire acteur
et paix dès la semaine prochaine dans
ses 80 pour lui c'était pas possible que
non alors vous avez une vocation assez
assez précoce un très jeune à l'école
vous alors ses membres ce qu'il allait
se coucher dany boon
évidemment il n'a pas droit de regarder
le film à la télé mais comme elle est
beaucoup d'imagination le lendemain à la
cantine et raconter le film qui l'avait
pas vu aller à la cantine je voyais
juste un bout de film et j'inventais la
fin on monte la suite du film
j'ai raconté ça mes copains et toujours
pas été justement très extraverti à
l'extérieur à l'école way et uzi du mime
dans votre chambre
c'est très beau l'an c'est complexe et à
part mes oreilles oui terriblement comme
vous d'ailleurs un petit peu long mais
ça m'a un peu passé oui c'est vrai je
veux plus long plus les j'ai les cheveux
assez long on voit moins oui et là vous
faites un truc que j'ai parlé avec votre
coiffeur l'arrêt pour vous faites une ré
comme ça je sais pas quoi voulez que je
fasse d'autre
bah je sais pas il m'a dit oui piscine
10 et au millimètre bien sûr je veux une
autre avec judith quand on le regarde
toi tu allais pas ici ça c'est pas
souvent c'est que des fois là avec vous
aussi vous regardons 17 pourquoi vous ne
tentez pas une autre notre coupe de
cheveux hpc si je faisais l'arrêt de
l'autre côté ça irait non padre un truc
un peu un peu fouillis quoi est ce un
peu à moi alors je peux pas moi donc
pourtant vous dormiez avec un élastique
autour des oreilles c'est ma mère qui
m'a donné ce complexe et quand j'étais
bébé elle me trouvais très très beau
souffle les oreilles décollées donc elle
me mettait un élastique une sorte de
bonnet comme ça qui me reconnaît les
oreilles et l enlever le matin ça
faisait tout
[Applaudissements]
vouziers bobigny gti dit j'étais beau de
trois quarts avec la tête légèrement
penchée comme ça parce qu'à l'envoyer
pas que j'avais les oreilles décollées y
avait un beau regard et les phillies et
à un torticolis
à un moment vous quittez la maison fait
du mime dans la revue gagné 7 cents
balles et pour vous c'est énorme parce
que votre père est bon pour vous c'est
une grosse somme
oui c'est ça et surtout que j'avais dans
la tête qu'il fallait que je fasse soit
la sncf où un concours genre ptt sncf où
ma mère me répéter ça en pleure tout le
temps qu'on voit la fiche de paye ta à
la fin du mois je disais mais c'est pas
écrit la poste et donc
et donc effectivement d'un seul coup
j'ai été embauché pour faire du mime
automate dans une grande surface et j'ai
eu un cachet le soir c'est 700 francs
l'humanité j'ai halluciné
j'ai vraiment galéré quand même parce
qu'à une fois j'ai vu là vous jouiez
dans des espèces de bruit oui il fallait
déplacer le baby foot pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir jouer quoi pour fabriquer une
espèce de seine s'est jamais au
téléphone quelqu'un qui me faisait jouer
au centre culturel vient faire via sahel
et lunaire et j'étais allé chez lui
je suis tombé dans un bistrot et
jeudi mais ya pas de scène indie baby
aux deux jeunes baby qui joue à la place
j'ai dit mais n'y a pas d'éclairage
nilesat et par année on s'est allumé
mais bon et je le soir arrive et je me
suis dit tant pis je vais jouer je me
suis envie de faire ça c'est mon rêve
quoi j'avais 16-17 ans et je donc je
reviens le soir il y avait donc la salle
bourrée donc quatre spectateurs est
bourré au comptoir dans le champ et
chantait déjà il vraiment bourré et je
touche je suis rentré sur scène en me
disant je vais tirer deux coups de feu y
avait un revolver un blanc pour les
faire taire pour pouvoir pour qu'ils
m'écoutent j'ai tiré deux coups de feu y
se sont tus effectivement il me regarder
comme ça et à ce moment là le berger
allemand du patron que j'avais pas vu
qui était derrière le comptoir me saute
dessus en croyant que j'attaque s
c'est vrai que tout ça est vrai une
bouffe la jambe le battre en direct qui
bouffent pas le comique avec les quatre
spectateurs
mort de rire piccola il arrache le chien
de mon genou et l'arrachement genou pour
chien et le
leur part en coulisse vous recherchez
enfin en coulisses en cuisine ce que
c'est les cuisines des grévistes je
cherche un os de poulet pour remplacer
ma rotule sa femme me fais un pansement
à la mayonnaise et c'est vrai il revient
samedi après midi j'ai mille chat dans
le braille quart temps dit il faut les
rigolos j'ai dû retourner sur scène il y
en a un des quatre qui m'a dit au milieu
du spectacle m'a dit monsieur il joue
plus alors voilà c'est tout c'est tout
le talent dont vous avez hérité de votre
mère ça c'est raconter des trucs exemple
mise en scène
il était évidemment des frais après je
me disais voilà on arrive maintenant à
la fin puisque un jeu vous rencontrer
thierry jolly le frère de sylvie joly pu
user vos premiers succès dont la déprime
qui est votre sketch le plus le plus
connu à l'époque maintenant c'est passé
vous faites toujours je me souviens pas
donc voilà régime non je vais bientôt
annie bonne
dany boon mesdames messieurs comment ça
va mieux a alors vous savez que votre
passage dans cette émission a changé ma
vie mais j'ai vu ça oui j'étais pas peu
fier la magnéto c'est oui alors vous
faites un truc que j'ai parlé avec votre
coiffeur l'arrêt pour vous faites une
règle comme ça je sais pas quoi je vais
croiser d'autres mais je sais pas il m'a
dit oui piscine glisséo mm bien sûr je
veux une autre usine avec judith quand
on le regarde quand elle est pas ici
c'est pas souvent c'est que des fois là
avec vous aussi vous regardons 17
pourquoi vous ne tentez pas une autre
notre coupe de cheveux hpc si je faisais
l'arrêt de l'autre côté ça ira
[Applaudissements]
atelier
si merci les enfants ah oui ça me va
très bien
vraiment je ne me souvenais plus à quel
point vous avez cette coupe de cheveux
de ringard l'époque
c'est très exactement quand j'ai
d'ailleurs c'est des images noir et
blanc mais en couleur non c'est ça que
des années 40
en tous les cas merci donc à changer de
vie tous complets contre les femmes
sachez que les hommes aussi
alors l'olympia et non du réchauffé
ouais mais tu sais au gaz en parfait
état donc dany boon du 12 février
jusqu'au 2 mars spectacle également
disponible en cassette vidéo savez
comment on fait attention
franck
continuez sur la vie privée dany boon on
va vous faire une interview au mensonge
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
ya un truc que je comprends pas chez
vous c'est pourquoi cette envie comme ça
vous avez absolument irrépressible de
sauter sur tout ce qui bouge c'est dû à
quoi c'est dû
oui parce que j'aime bien et c'est tout
frais tout ce qui bouge
quel que soit le même pas que des femmes
que c'est vrai et c'est depuis tout
petit comme c'est parce que j'ai vécu
j'étais élevé avec un chien et un mâle
labrador de grande taille
et puis c'est une liaison très peu de
temps
sa durée et depuis je me manque c'est
que les filles les filles si ce soir
j'étais pas rassurés de savoir que vous
veniez valérie la maquilleuse la
dernière fois la wii elle voulait pas
mais elle est où ce que j'ai détruit à
lui rendre judith elle supporte comme ça
que vous la trompiez à tout bout de
champ
dit elle accepte ça elle adore elle dit
vas-y continue ce formidable
ouais c'est là c'est ta voix mais vont
souffrir quand même non pas du tout non
parce qu'elle fait pareil qui peut
arrêter des boîtes échangistes quand
même non j'ai arrêté
oui et non j'y vais je veux boire des
verres et puis des gens me touche faut
dire dany boon que vous avez un sexe
énorme tout petit minuscule
ah ça c'est très étonnant et je m'en
suis rendu compte bêtement on l'a dit
quelqu'un regardez mon sexe dans des
genres ou qu'est-ce que tu es loin et il
m'a vu à nantes est doublé à un moment
vous avez essayé de remplacer le sexe
par la drogue oui appris beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs bien
accroché énormément de cocaïne et là
j'ai complètement arrêté
ouais parce que je
parce que j'avais appelé la police quand
on dit leur venaient en croyant que
c'était de l'anthrax et
[Musique]
c'est du coup je me suis fait gauler
mais maintenant c'est des manques du jeu
je prends de l'anthrax maintenant faut
dire qu'il faut beaucoup d'argent à dany
boon c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
dépensier je dépense a énormément de
l'argent des autres
ouais c'est ça le problème c'est que les
gens s'en rendent compte
benoît 150 mètres carrés rue de la pompe
trois cent cinquante mille francs par
mois par jour 800 mètres carrés rue de
la pompe deux mercedes 600 oui j'en ai
déjà dit oui
plusieurs couleurs tout ça même jusqu'à
quand même et alors fait space de goût
du luxe comme ça si vous avez deux
assistants qui vous allumez vos pétard
c'est toute la journée
oui on assiste en toge
ils font comme ça avec des judith à
cette baby sitter cette baisse est là en
un an après une huitième pour s'occuper
des sept autres une par jour de la
semaine c'est incroyable c'est vrai avec
qui je vais au club d'échangistes pour
boire des verres on est d'un seul coup
des gens nous touche cher et bientôt dé
quand même puis des trois mille balles
au téléthon c'est sympa j'ai appelé j'ai
fait une promesse et j'ai rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
ouais vous êtes du côté des possédants
maintenant ça y est l'invité berisha
j'adore j'adore 1
ah oui je connais des ministres et tout
ça hein vous avez à droite maintenant
dans cette franchise
même limitée sonne droite arrêts bah oui
votre rêve vous l'avez déclaré votre
rêve c'est un madelin qui serait plus à
droite ou un le pen plus moderne plus
moderne et mieux coiffée plus personne
ne veut vous donner son numéro de
portable
non mais j'ai joué par contre leur prend
leur portable à la main je vais pas
changer un petit peu de latitude la non
vous n'aurez pas être un peu plus
sympathique avec les gens je t'emmerde
non je sais pas vous apprendre les juge
pas la solidarité la tolérance la
compassion sont pas des valeurs un peu
plus humaniste non gg toutes ses valeurs
elle 100 au bac en jeu qu'en j'écrase
quelqu'un je m'arrête maintenant
et si on vous croiser avec l'arrêt on
vous écrase j'accueille michèle laroque
jr d'armand et d'animaux
voilà sur l'iphone
vous voulez qu'on commence comme ça ce
soit les places mais bon on sait qu'ils
sont comme ça va si on avait dit avant
gérard là et dany ici on change en cours
d'émission opposition on fait un
programme on s'y tient commence à me
casser les couilles cette histoire est
un berlin à bonsoir vous êtes ici tous
les trois pour [ __ ] dure le nouveau
film de gabriel aghion à qui on doit
déjà [ __ ] douce a cité lui ouais
l'ordure il y avoue 3 plus jacques
dutronc sur un scénario de gabriel
aghion et de bertrand blier
le pitch qui fait le pitch mais toi tu
as compris alors gérard et dany vous
vivez ensemble vous êtes un couple
installé tout va bien pas que c'est tout
va bien dans votre vie d'autant plus que
vous allez avoir un enfant un enfant
dont gérard et le père et michel la mère
porteuse voilà bien voilà mais le
problème c'est que michel tombe
amoureuse de jacques dutronc mais voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe michel après
après ils sont pas contents du tout les
deux pacsés et il essaie de tout faire
foirer
et jacques disparaît voilà et moi je
suis très fâché voilà et je les quitte
voilà avec le bébé qu'est ce qui se
passe après qu'est-ce que je le prends
pas comme ça tout le temps d'accord
bon ça c'était le pitch voulait quand on
regarde la bande annonce
ah mais si vous voulez vous regardez
tous les trois votre caméra et vous
dites
magnéto serge meunier tous annoncer
ensemble voilà ça décale tous les plats
sains alors on se connaît bien tous les
cadres je vous ai je vous ai souvent
interviewé je vous ai fait un petit peu
toutes les interviews que j'avais alors
malgré tout je suis arrivé comme à
récupérer a récupéré quelques questions
que je vous avais jamais posée ça
s'appelle les questions jamais posé
[Musique]
cette brune c'est des questions que j'ai
ramassé un peu partout dit content de
votre voiture
oui je vous remercie ou est bien claire
chazal elle vous excite bas maintenant
plus philippe torreton
du coup vous êtes pour l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'europe
je ne sais pas mais personne serbe je
n'en sais rien j'ai tjs pas ce caisson
pour 18 parce que oui les arguments ce
qu'ils sont cons 10 n'ont rien 70
millions + majorité musulmane
ça fera tous les 12es quelques pour cent
de voix obtient aujourd'hui quelle est
ta vision de la corse
on continue vous êtes toujours au parc
des princes pourtant de la pelouse entre
c'est moi le chopper plus en tant
qu'acteur ou en tant que chanteur monroe
c'est kif kif bourricot pareil peu
importe ce que vous dites quoi
un peu ça vous dirait de tourner une
fiction pour tf1 oui on rajoutera des
rires montent à 2 par dieu ne faudrait
pas qu'il arrête maintenant le bonheur
ah oui le québec n 1 gérard qu'est-ce
que oui
vous aimeriez qu'on efface quel film de
votre filmographie teulé que j'ai fait
avec giovanni ça s'était très mal passé
entre voilà c'est nous mais pour des
questions plutôt très personnelle sinon
aucun passe quand on les accepte on y va
avec son coeur après vous avez maigri et
vous non comme j'ai maigri oui bien vous
êtes fait la russie en réjouis
vous pensez qu'on va encore devoir se
taper la canicule cet hiver non sur le
meur de toute façon à partir du moment
où rafa rafael à la canicule il était
bien évident qu'il n'allait pas faire
chaud oui ça va bien cette flambée du
baril ça vous a fait pas trop lui du
baril 53 dollars encore ce matin est ce
que ça change au quotidien a priori de
star vault 10 fuel de la cuve de fioul
sur votre quotidien généralement soir
c'est le rock la couette sympa à lire en
ce moment en ce moment qu'est-ce qui
aurait ne st pas lire en journaux au
carton tout cas plutôt la maison à
l'école occe boeuf l'espace et la
question sinon je voulais pas le croire
mais là je suis content j'ai mis en ce
moment relation les jeux de pouvoir ok
ok d'accord ok ok ok ok aucun cas la
question suivante elle vous la voulez
parce que si vous voulez oui comme c'est
à dire que ces exécutions et là celle-là
vous la voulez vous c'est la question
c'est pas comme ça que je demande à voir
tu vas me oh non non non non vous la
voulez oui ou non la première fois que
j'ai rencontré il m'a pas dit vous la
voulez pas sinon il n'aurait pas eu
dany vous avez écouté nouvel album de
sardo nom d'annie vous avez écouté le
nouvel album de dany nom d'alli vous
pensez que ça va baisser l'immobilier
non ça a demandé michel il vous manque
parfois joe dassin
oui beaucoup voilà la bonne question
une belle réponse oui mais là c'était
bien faire parce que je sais qu'on va
leur faire faire exactement
michel il vous manque parfois joe dassin
oui beaucoup
avec messieurs
octobre dans un cinéma près de chez vous
alors dany boon vous êtes à l'olympia
oui du 24 novembre 2 janvier
oui je pense que vous allez faire un
tabac ça se présente bien ça
ravi d'être à l'olympia c'est une salle
mythique d'anissa va alors oui très bien
donc nouvelle vie nouvelle femme
vacances sur un yacht 1
et puis cette patate toujours non
pourquoi je suis prêt à les suivre en
vacances sur un yacht à moi je les ai
vus dans voici sur un yacht un nom à
l'inversé un ponton ouais bah c'est joli
comme légende
dany boon traverse important sympa pour
la fille donc l'olympia les 24 qui rit
ardisson bonsoir bonsoir c'est la
sixième année septième année de tous les
7e année est-ce que parfois vous ne
pouvez pas des moments de lassitude pas
du tout non j'ai toujours la même pâte a
toujours la même patate au début oui
mais on regarde tueries continuent on
vous suit armentières 1-0 deuil mais la
patate quand même
michèle laroque pension vous avez tourné
de notre premier film américain
ah oui aussi c'est quoi ce film
américain car c'est j'ai acheté les
droits de deux
livre un livre français qui s'appelait
pictures j'avais déjà par une bombe
range toujours en train de baisser de
développer et aussi j'ai acheté un livre
anglais qui s'appelle les droits d'un
livre qui s'appelle dont tu mens tu me
dises the night et c'est une comédie
romantique très sympathique et ça que je
voudrais faire là bas
voilà qui regardent ils sont bons ce
soir et pourquoi cette envie du prime
time toujours au plus tard ils savent où
tu fais pas cette émission si je pense
que ça me suffit alors pourquoi vous
faites des prime time mais pourquoi tu
fais des prime time je sais pas t'as pas
envie d'arrêter ces primes tard ici
alors dit de la caméra vas-y les gardes
ton coeur dix mois la prime time
j'arrête mais on arrête mais c'est pour
ça que c'est moins drôle bien écouter
l'info n'était pas parvenu à monter à
terry je suis désolé pour cette gamme
est ce que est ce que dominique segall
est content catherine sur le terrain
libyen mais je crois qu'il s'est pendu
dans la loge qui arrivait bien gilbert
bécaud je trouve c'est bien alors
carcela à l'eau
oui
bonsoir le mini bonsoir avait l'unique
voulait savoir si j'étais content de la
façon dont ils ont vendu le film ou
s'ils avaient oublié quelque chose mais
bien auquel cas nous pourrions leur
ajouté je ne vends rien oui je ne vous
revient
il en a bien parlé girard les mois mais
lui à la fin c'est lui moi j'étais plus
sur la mairie d'armentières dominique
segall bonsoir je vous connais très peu
en province est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter
je suis qu'un attaché de presse jean
alors lui allait très bien parlé du
canal afin qu'il a repris la parole
c'est bien oui parce qu'il fallait dire
qu'il est un monsieur comme comment tu
as trouvé michel la prestation de michel
hamel a non parce que j'ai dormi avant
de venir
ah oui et là ça y est tu vois beaucoup
d'électrochoc bon je vous laisse mon
père si on va merci
moyo
il a vendangé
[Musique]
j'avais accueilli d'avis bourde
c'est sa meilleure que les deux puis
trois
[Musique]
j'étais alors s'est établi à bien le mot
a été attrapé une promo exception les
niayes général rama yade est parfait
d'une sobriété magnifique talent et
l'unité non non européens c'est sa
terrible hénin beaumont jusqu'à quand et
jusqu'à quand il était encore des
interviews parallèle et l'otan depuis
longtemps
je suis né à bamako
pourtant pas si longtemps
et maintenant mesdames messieurs comme
emprunteur si dany boon
ça se passe bien l'européen jeudi les
gens n'ont plus besoin de taper à
rivedoux d'hénin-beaumont hénin-beaumont
ayala anciennement hénin liétard ma
région
faut partir en vacances dans leur pays
ça s'est bien passé pas très bien tu es
venu en hélico là non je suis venu en
voiture et après en moto pour revenir
vite érodée et le gabriel jeu je prends
souvent tir ardisson sur l'art et la
moto c'est un con hélas non il m'a dit
accrochez-vous autour de ma taille c'est
ce qui fait de lui le fait que les
tornades
j'y arrivais pas mal vieilli la mini
moto j'ai un peu vite plus vite que
julia déjà un foulard sur les très bien
non là on rigole mme alors bon écoutez
mesdames messieurs pas tourné autour du
pot trop longtemps le film dont dany
boon vient parler ce soir et il est
maire d'un an
c'est un super grand film c'est énorme
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
s'appelle joyeux noël sorti une
christian carion avec diane kruger
guillaume canet alors le pitch c'est
fraternisation des troupes françaises
écossaise allemande le soir de noël noël
ils sortent des tranchées et ils se
parlent et ils se serrent la main voilà
et ce film m'a complètement c'est une
histoire assez extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire alors l'attaché de presse
dominique segall m'avait dit tu vas
pleurer
il avait raison j'ai pleuré et je vois
pas qui peut ne pas pleurer en voyant ce
film saddam hussein l'humanité commis
sous saddam hussein c'est un film
bouleversant mais vraiment incroyable et
ça parce que ça fait appel à tous les
deux nos bons sentiments à notre bon
côté à la bonne partie de nous mêmes et
c'est un film qui est très récompensant
parce que quand on sort de là on se sent
meilleur donc goûté on va pas discuter
voilà un il est tard aller voir le film
puisque j'ai à dire vous ne le
regretterez pas je m'avance pas beaucoup
en disant ça parce que le film a obtenu
une standing-ovation à cannes 2001 et 10
minutes voilà depuis dix ans d'amour non
mais les gens applaudissaient pendant la
projection étonnant pour les uns un
métier le film est sélectionné aux
oscars à hollywood
donc voila et qu'est ce que je vous dise
de deux plus gros carton bronca en
perspective vos cartons
sur ces genres les choristes enfin ça
c'est vraiment un film magnifique
effectivement en plus c'est en une
histoire vraie fin christian carion a
très bien réussi son odeur son pari que
de parler de sas qui synthétise très
très bien ce qui s'est passé et que je
ne sais pas dans les livres d'histoire
ça qui est étonnant on n'a pas pu
tourner en france parce que les
militaires dans un premier temps accepté
qu'on tombe sur un terrain militaire
français les généraux ont lu le scénario
ils nous ont refusé le tournage qui a
été reculée
on a été au bruit mais quand on est
toujours pas qu'on en parle
obligés d'aller tourner en roumanie
ouais et voilà et c'est cesser c'est un
moment magnifique c'est ils ont fait
l'europe avant tout le monde
ils seront du compte deux ils ont fait
ils ont fait preuve de libre arbitre en
fait ces hommes qui étaient
conditionnées à la n 2 de la race
étrangère si on leur apprenait des
poèmes soins dans le film au début les
pouilles les poésies des enfants on dit
il faut exterminer la race allemande ce
sont des assassins des violeurs des
égorgeurs et et il avait ça dans la tête
il se disait que c'est qu'en face
c'était des monstres et en fait ils sont
ils se sont arrêtés à noël 1914 et ils
ont dit non grâce à la musique
d'ailleurs c'est quand la belle sort
d'un ténor allemand et sabrina et
le la cornemuse écossaise répond et d'un
seul coup la musique serait comme elle
est universelle la rencontre secret quoi
et il fera ils font preuve de libre
arbitre
ils savent que que ça va leur être fatal
et ils ont le courage de fraterniser et
ces gens qui étaient considérés comme
comme des lâches et des traîtres en fait
étaient des visionnaires et des airs
très courageux et des roues vrai héros
s'est élancé de guerre de 14 qui a été
quand même là la fin de l'europe
on a envoyé se faire tuer des
générations entières de jeunes gens de
20 ans a tué l'europe l'europe ne plus
jamais été ce qu'elle a il est avant
c'était des millions de morts pour rien
puisque on se battait contre les
allemands bons et ce film d'un seul coup
c'est une antidote extraordinaire à ce
poison qu'est la guerre
cette scène quelques se trouve
magnifique qui résume bien le film qui
est très très belle et kiev qui est vrai
qu est réellement existé qui montrent
bien l'absurdité de cette guerre comme
beaucoup de guerre c'est que ils ont
fraternisé et ils ont dit on arrête
maintenant on a fêté noël nouvel an on
avait fait la nourriture on a fait des
matches de foot on est bon on va on va
se mettre
on recommence à se battre et le
lendemain il yal officiellement et c'est
une histoire vraie il arrive au bord des
tranchées françaises
il a failli se faire tuer d'ailleurs
parlé par les tireurs et l'officier
français lui dit mais on aurait pu vous
tirer dessus on a dit qu ont recommencé
à se battre il dit non je viens vous
voir parce que on va vous bombardez de
l'arrière dans 10 minutes et je vous
propose de venir vous abritez chez nous
leurs et il ya les soldats français et
anglais écossais qui vont s'abriter dans
les tranchées allemandes et le français
vient une demi-heure plus tard en disant
on va riposter
venez chez nous à leur tour guerre à
l'amiable
d'ailleurs si au final alors que dans
les écoles ce film voilà c'est ce qu'ils
voient là un film monde shoah dans les
écoles c'est très bien il faut aussi
montrer ce film pour que les gens voient
ce que c'était cette guerre de tranchées
et voit comment des hommes ont résisté à
ça c'est un très grand film
allez-y là vous perdez pas un niveau de
pognon ni votre temps c'est génial
garder son libre arbitre et ça se perd
beaucoup en passant le discours de
lévesque voit la fin du film j'étais
rire est un discours de bush
ouais du président bush ces îles il a
repris le discours de l'époque
oui la guerre du bien contre le mal
l'extermination de la race étrangers
enfin et vous alors vous d'un seul coup
ça y est on découvre que derrière le
comique aux oreilles décollées
il ya un acteur aux oreilles décollées
un très bon acteur vous êtes excellent
vraiment excellent dans le film
guillaume canet très bien aussi un
vraiment très émouvant guillaume il est
au bord des larmes du début à la fin du
film est vraiment très bien diane kruger
aussi enfin vraiment c'est tout le monde
est bien anciens films comment dirais-je
assez classique à dents ça dans sa
facture a cessé c'est pas un film
moderne c'était un film un peu
traditionnelle même très lyrique en
simple accélérer qualité française un
peu kitsch même mais c'est très puissant
un certain moment on se demande comment
ces films et quoi on a regardé on est
pris par le tenait dans les bassins
s'appelle badauds
et j j
oui bonjour julie ferrier oui je suis
allé la voir un spectacle l'année
dernière oui j'ai très mal et au petit
palais des glaces
elle est géniale ouais elle mais elle
m'a fait penser à zhouqu
elle m'aide en sondant le pad en
inventions dans le délire dans elle est
géniale et voilà d'ailleurs elle fait ma
première partie à l'olympia à partir du
5 km 10 fois les lave linge à la main
téléphonie en disant il faut aller la
voir
la géniale si on m'a dit ça ouais mais
au bout d'un an je lui disais au bout
d'un moment on va dire attention dany
bull est en 2e partie de julie ferrier
l'olympia même si c'est quand l'olympia
à partir du 5 mars
non c'est à partir des 5 avril bras 2006
s'était pas alors continué sa descente
en 2e partie de julie ferrier
alors comment ça va avec à elle tient
bien ses cuisses à sebha serial killer
mais c'est un serial zikeurs parce que
j'avais fait un enfant encore on a un
bébé c'est vrai mais combien d'enfants
que j'ai trois enfants avec trois femmes
différentes
c'est possible vérifiez avec oui oui ben
eddie barclay je voulais lui vous faites
des enfants sans marié obligatoirement
près c'est là on est mariés
on est très heureux et tellement cher
plaint me portent beaucoup effectivement
champ plus que chance elle me rend très
heureux et c'est une femme merveilleuse
vous allez découvrir parce que je pense
qu'il ya elle va faire le blind test
vous avez apporté vous avez ramer dur
pour la séduire non oui j'ai ramé way ah
ouais j'ai ramé et surtout comme en
général quand j'ai testé une boîte il y
avait un concert de jazz et le patron
m'accueille il me fait robes baby boom
fenêtre c'est bienvenu mètre carré viiip
mener mais si vous êtes arrivé il y
avait un bar et je voyais à elle au bar
avec son train une amie et là au concert
je disais je vais aller au bar non pas
une vedette pop habibou ils mangent
arriva quand même allé au bar ils voient
que je regarde d'y aller
un gta du ciné-parc voilà la beauté il
est allé la voir sans me demander en
disant tu veux que je te présente de
beaux bébés et elle a fait non non je
vois pourquoi non et voilà j'ai fait
c'est génial vous êtes converti au
judaïsme pour l'épouser c'est
enfin oui je suis combien du g10 mais
pas parce spécialement pour l'épouser
vous êtes un bon juif
oui on va voir interview bon juif alors
gagné en quelle année juive sommes-nous
sans 1766 braves est ce que vous
connaissez les cinq grandes fêtes juives
alors bonne blague louis bien cela qui
pour wii recherche and away paix sarrouy
pâques noël parce que jésus était juif
j'étais juste souccot et chats vois tu
ce côté chabot voilà mais c'est bien
déjà moi je trouve que vous avez bien
vous avez bien appris est ce que vous
allez fêter noël quand même cette année
noël et rajoutant les deux web comment
dit-on bonne année shana tova dia à
quelle heure est il s'est arrêté de
bosser de vendredi ça dépend coucher du
soleil
d'accord vous trouvez drôle le nouveau
spectacle de dieudonné je trouve ça
triste je trouve qu'il est plus drôle du
tout est justement en parlant d' extrême
et d'extrémisme par rapport au
conditionnement des gens et par rapport
aux jeunes je trouve qu'il est justement
dans cet excédent cet extrémisme et que
c'est désespérant de le voir s'enfoncer
tout seul comment appelle-t-on dieu chez
les juifs à gauche m on n'a pas le droit
de le dire et de chaînes optionnelles à
dos et un dc9 le patron que marc la
circoncision l'alliance avec abraham ça
fait mal j'étais déjà circoncis moi toi
et moi comme je suis en fait j'ai eu
deux les trois religions moi je les mots
d'été c'est à dire que le mon père était
kabyle donc
il c'est un mélange de religion
musulmane et juive
parce que dans kabylie à une grogne qui
s'appelle la kahina qui était une grande
reine juive
voilà ma mère et fille timide ouais donc
du coup j'ai été circoncis enfants et
j'ai fait aussi ma communion c'est bien
donc je rassemble son jeu rassembler
panique
c'est un peu la même chose les fêtes en
vacances toute l'année voilà alors dany
qui est isaac à part d'être le barman de
la croisière s'amuse
c'est le fils de sarah tisseyre abraham
isaac et jacob sont étroits dans quel
coin à moïse at il reçu l'étape de la
loi sur mont sinaï
c'est quoi le talmud
le talmud c'est une réflexion écrite des
deux qui depuis des siècles sur la torah
en fait et qui ça explique la torah et
ça ça pose les questions sur la torah la
torah qui est qui et le livre de dieu
quoi l'habit blanc fait enfin donnée par
dieu aux hommes c'est bien vous y
connaissez vachement bien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait hara nou ka
[Rires]
c'est une fait beaucoup pour les surtout
pour les enfants l'ont leur faire un
cadeau par jour
donc les enfants l'adorent et manger des
rillettes non je ne mange pas de rien
comment j'ai encore du homard nom du
lapin vous en mangez du lapin aviaire
oui ça nous c'est bien non qu'est ce
t'en penses et là bas c'est en tout cas
j'attends moins bon jus non mais ça
m'intéresse mais c'est venu en fait
aussi beaucoup par ma psy enfin ouais
j'ai une psy qu'est 13 juive ashkénaze
et je me suis beaucoup intéressé à la
psychanalyse et la psychanalyse tire ses
sources justement du talmud et de la
torah c'est une sorte de dans le
judaïsme laïque bravo dany boon
en joyeux noël christian carion
en cadets
fugère le ville d'avoir
[Musique]
ok
dray pour convertir à l'islam carte
ch'tis vous devez draguer une fille
parle en lui parlant juste i o latorre
julie ferrier et sinon que coco queue de
boeuf sa gueule ou on s'en va
ou bien à sa sortie de pierre
aujourd'hui par le trac était de blagues
eux monsieur madame crypte où on t'a
fils quand il appelle monsieur et madame
tripes comme il l'appelle gaitan moon
[Musique]
quel succès c'est dingue je savais pas
que l'union était là lui qui voit la
carrière de miu miu ça va ça n'a pas
empêché de faire une carrière à ses
dépens j'ai fini un pioupious cas pas
fait carrière carrière ça va et il ya
elle ça va bien là et là elle va bien
elle va très bien on va lui demander mon
appel yeah yeahs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un invité mystère tu as posé des
questions et on répond par oui ou par
non de l'autre devinez qui c'est est ce
que tu es président tu me cacher c'était
génial apparemment bon ce qu'on va faire
si on va égaliser un peu et on va
désépaissir on va retirer des volumes
commencent on vous raconte lire
également
bayrou 8
t'as déjà du boulot ce soir un boulot et
j'avais une question on est sur quelle
chaîne
cette journée là on est sur l'a2 encore
toujours là deux toujours là 2
et bien tout superbe et très vivement on
sent ça qu'on l'a fait pour l'heure s'il
s'était converti au judaïsme pour vous
mais il a changé le bout du nez alors tu
restes de boutoir nantes et asilah telle
observation
c'est le sens 108 et viser un incroyable
la ville le et ça c'est quoi
maintenant une fiche de bongani vous
êtes ici pour un film et je vous êtes
ici bravo d'être avec ma femme avec
votre femme est ce normal
tellement mignonne c'est vrai oui vous
êtes ici pour un film dont vous êtes
scénariste réalisateur co producteur
acteur si ça se présente ne va pas
demander et puis à qui la faute
sur les conseils de laurent baffie est
faible pour l'assurer conseils avisés
alors ce film s'appelle la maison du
bonheur c'est l'adaptation de votre
pièce la vie de chantier
le titre a été choisi par yaël qui ne
connaissait pas la chanson de francis
lalanne sinon vous auriez pas pressée de
dire non
non non elle ça non un g1 comme la
chanson we france la main elle m'a fait
france anne de supporter l'équipe de
france
les maires ya elle était inscrite au
générique du film est toujours eu et a
fait honneur à la tradition elle a
travaillé sur le film vous avez déclaré
elle a été mon miroir sur toutes les
phases de l'écriture elle a visionné les
rush
elle a suivi de montage tout ça en
s'occupant du mouflet en plus non il ya
six et il n' est d'ailleurs le même jour
que yaël né le même jour à 2h10 et les
juifs c'est pour un gâteau pour que
c'est l'économie s'est laissé marrant
dany sérieusement à quel point les
femmes de votre vie ont toujours été
mêlé à votre travail
comment ça se fait mais j'ai beaucoup
travaillé tiré jeudi et on a très bon
n'a pas vécu tellement longtemps
ensemble
non on s'est pas marié déjà mla n'a pas
réussi à avoir d'enfants
et voilà nommé judith godrèche déjà été
très impliquée dans votre vie
professionnelle
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce métier les
attaques de vous et s'est assise à côté
de moi pour voir qu'en juillet si je rie
et c'est vrai dans les traits pour nom
mais pourquoi vous êtes si impliqué avec
vos aux femmes dans le travail je suis
pas impliqué avec mes femmes c'est plus
sympa il s'est pas d'abord ce mammifère
de femmes c'est une histoire de
rencontre donc il se trouve que
effectivement il ya elle que j'ai donc
enlevé de suisse puisqu'elle et les
suissesses
voilà la quitter son travail il se
trouve qu'elle a qu'elle a des dons pas
mal de dons et voilà et puis on
travaille ensemble
effectivement elle a fait donc sur la
pièce elle a la cote chez gilles soualem
pour l'accent portugais
elle a fait les chorégraphies café de la
danse à la fait toutes les grandes
chorégraphies de mon spectacle à chanter
sur des chansons dont spectacle à la
maison du bonheur donc de dany boon avec
michèle laroque daniel prévost zinedine
soualem laurent gamelon line renaud et
et vous bien sûr sortie de 7 juin alors
le pitch c'est un mari radin qui décide
d'être enfin généreuse va bien les
cheveux bas
alors le pitch donc c'est l'histoire
d'un mari radin qui décide d'être enfin
généreux avec sa femme en lui offrant
une maison de campagne
mais pour faire des économies il fait
confiance à un agent immobilier douteux
qui lui proposent des ouvriers foire
voilà et là surprise se transforme en
cauchemar
et ça se termine en pur délire vraiment
c'est une catastrophe c'est très drôle
merci et je suis venu avec lui aussi
intervenir
oui
messieurs comment ça va bien il est prêt
pour la promo l'a pas mal
amal a pas marre de répéter que là on va
répéter un peu la promo au départ dany
boon cette histoire de travaux est
inspiré d'une histoire vécue
oui l'histoire des moulures par exemple
hélas la baguette entre autres c'était
un appartement genre haussmannien la
jolie avec des belles moulures et
l'architecte voit une baguette de
téléphone en plastique et voilà il dit
il prend un de ces gars il dit tu me
vois tu m'enlèves la baguette là non 1
ils se parlent assez c est le gars news
ça j'aurais dû me méfier je fais bien
et puis voilà et donc on part voir le
truc parler les plans les machins trucs
et on revient à un quart d'heure après
il avait enlevé toutes les moulures sauf
la tête ça y est j'y croyais que la
baguette était plus moderne en plastique
donc il se disait ça faut que ça reste
bel et bien et bien il avait fait un
petit ami l'avait fait un petit avec le
on aurait dit qu'il allait faire un
petit feu de camp et j'ai dit les
moulures les moulures ça il m'a dit ah
ça va vous frappez pas gelé remettre et
les a remis un peu de travers il ya
aussi la peinture dans le sanitaire la
peinture dans le sanitaire c'est quand
il avait mis la peinture dans le
sanitaire afssa avait bouché le
sanitaire oui ça c'est récent sa wii
fait le félon vas voir c'est ça sert
essence et il ya trois semaines à la
campagne
le nom il avait vidé oui de la peinture
qui a séché dans un coup de l'évacuation
de toilette
donc quelqu'un nous inviter à tirer la
chasse d'eau et au lieu de la facture et
ça fait le dos l'autre côté et on était
dans l'embarras et ça a fait le long des
murs comme ça et donc non ils ont été
réussis ont dû tout cas chez eon pour
refaire les coudes tous les coudes vous
êtes angoissé dany boon oui ça c'est la
question
une question qu'on va te poser beaucoup
dans la promotion vous êtes un angoissé
dany boon est ce que vous étiez vous
accédez à la caméra non j'étais pas gt
non j'étais ça allait non j'étais pas
trop angoissé non j'ai beau j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur le film en
préparation justement pour pour pas
l'être dany boon vous préférez devant ou
derrière
peut-être un peu posé la question ariel
qui me référence est beaucoup plus
confortable d'être devant oui que
derrière votre passé de storyboarder et
photographes vous a aidé mais c'est tout
à fait vrai dirigé mois que vous êtes
bien renseigné
je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous faites
licence qui de le france de lagardère
votre émission et je trouve ça
complètement quand
oui j'étais dessinateur gt2 et
storyboarder donc effectivement j'ai
appris à découper une histoire en plan
qu est ce qu on pense évidemment
d'autres il a beaucoup bossé sur ce
sujet il a beaucoup bossé sur ce faire
il a bossé groupe c de 5 heures du matin
à minuit tu te rien oui c'est bien vrai
nom j'ai bossé énormément là on prépare
la promo là il y avait un truc super
drôle sur le tournage je peux raconter
une anecdote eu ce que tu veux en
escrime pour une de ces deux-là dos de
baisser au tir et patrick si tu
m'entends
wesley encore au moins une année
[Applaudissements]
la maison qu'on détruit qu'on a remis en
état d'ailleurs pas avec la même équipe
la maison qu'on a des trucs se trouve à
maisons laffitte et donc au début on n'a
pas eu les autorisations de tournage
s'est scindé le député maire de maisons
laffitte
chaque milliard pour la non pendant ce
milliard mais bien ouais mais bon voilà
mon bref il nous donne pas les
autorisations et grâce à claude berri on
les obtient il nous dit il est dit et il
fait à la production il dit voilà je
veux rencontrer dany boon en tournée
pendant un mois la balle je veux je veux
rencontrer dany boon je dis non
maintenant je travaille j'ai pas le
temps ça m'intéresse pas et puis non non
non non et la production de 10 insiste
en disant ça serait mieux qu'ils
viennent parce qu'il a finalement
accepté qu'on tourne dans sa ville c'est
vrai c'est sympa et puis voilà il n'a
qu'à venir pendant l'heure du déjeuner
ça dure une heure et après voilà déjà
avec lui il est très sympathique et
items beaucoup mangent dit d'accord donc
il arrive juste en train de travailler
g on dit bonjour monsieur milliard on va
là je termine puis on lui dit voilà on
est pause déjeuner on va à la cantine
est sur le chemin de la cantine et se
tourne vers moi puis me fait vous vous
faites quoi sur le sur le film j'ai dit
mais je suis acteur j'ai écrit tout ça
et je réalise unis veut vous produisez
aussi le belge du produit enfin en
coproduction mais comme comme moteur
mais pas mais oui pourquoi il me dit
vous êtes claude berri en fait non je
suis elie semoun
allez je le dis je suis elie semoun il
me fait homme et oui mais oui pardon il
y excusez moi eh bien il me dit ça va
pas fort en ce moment avec dieudonné
je dis oui on a séparé on a un peu des
soucis va faire de la politique comme
vous c'est pas facile là c'est sûr et on
marche on dort une par jeu par la ville
et ses monuments il fait mais il est où
dany boon évident mais je vous le
présenter et je vois laurent gamelon
donc eux qui fait d'omettre que voilà
qui est là où je fais a dit bien
député maire jacques meyer qui veut dire
bonjour jeudi discrètement que je suis
allé chez moune qu'il est dany boon ça
et il fait un homonyme ou nous je vous
adore depuis longtemps bravo pour tout
ce que vous faites il lui dit à lui
ouais
sur ce je pense à zinedine soualem qui
est dans le film mais je vais vous
connaissez smaïn
on s'est retrouvés à table avec une
grande partie du show business français
personne ne correspondait la bonne
personne et il y avait juste à sa
secrétaire qui est assise à côté de moi
qui qui va qui était morte de trouille
qui me disait dans l'oreille dominique
ça va la promo on va bien nager à
surveiller non non je hais ce qu'on
pourrait dire de plus sur le prince
britannique est toujours sous
tranquillisants non non je suis rassuré
il revient donc à mesure dominique à
pékin moi je pars contre suis inquiet
pour l'avenir havrais qu'est ce qu'on va
devenir m'arrive c'est bien moi quand
c'est pas grave mais nos films de
spectacles
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va tous se
donner la mort alors dany vous êtes
quand même un acteur maintenant assez
reconnus parce que dans ce joyeux noël
et une formidable j'étais nommé aux
césar
ensuite il la doublure de webber avec
gad elmaleh bientôt mon meilleur ami de
patrice leconte avec daniel auteuil ça
ça commence à exister un oui oui c'est
d'ailleurs la chance de tourner qu'avec
patrice leconte est de donner la
réplique à daniel auteuil pendant trois
mois s'était formée avant un très beau
rôle en plus un très très beau film je
les vis gens pensent yael naim et direct
il n'est pas bon mais je crois que il
n'y a plus qu'une chose à faire
maintenant que vous êtes un grand acteur
dany boon c'est une interview alain
delon
pensez vous que le public aime dany boon
dany boon pense que le public aime dany
boon mais mais mais pas autant que dany
boon ne s'aiment et dany boon et le jour
où le public chemra autant que dany boon
scène le public sera ce que c'est
qu'être dany boon
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez vous de dany boon l'homme
dany boon pense que les femmes ont
beaucoup de chance que dany boon soit un
homme pour vous dany boon est synonyme
de quoi franchement je suis dany boon
est très déçue que thierry ardisson pose
cette question pensez vous que dany boon
sur le plus grands comédiens français
dany boon est un grand comédien c'est
vrai renesas pas français et les
ch'timis ah oui vous pensez que dany
boon peut tout jouer
dany boon ne pourra jamais jouer dany
boon c'est c'est beaucoup trop durs car
il faut être dany boon et en même temps
être dany boon et jose dany boon c'est
impossible
dany boon a complètement défoncé est-ce
que vous pensez que dany boon laissera
une trace dans le cinéma français une
trace de pneu oui est ce que dany boon
espère avoir bientôt une rue à son nom
mais dany boon des attire ardisson
rentrer dany boon dans son gps et tu
verras est ce que dany boon est lui
aussi une star au japon
dany boon effectivement était au japon
récemment avec un certain alain delon et
les japonais disait je veux dire qui est
cet homme à côté de dany boon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carte conseil d'ami c'est quoi c'est
parce que c'est que vous devez donner un
conseil à maurice barthélémy pour lui
expliquer comment faire avec judith
godrèche 7/4 vraiment l étreint concept
car l'arbre en une autre mais il sait
très bien faire j'avais eu très très
bien ah oui moi le se passe bien mais
très très bien et voilà il monfils
nouvelle il adore d'ailleurs c'est un
super beau père il a fait un très bon
film en plus papa ouais karch si vous
devez nous chanter les corons de pierre
bachelet en pleurant en pleurant tu
connais les cours oui bien sûr le sénat
vote ya quelques électeurs oh non j'ai
tous les corons les hommes des videurs
de fonds
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]